these other areas and see parallels even
though you might be from very different
disciplines
what's cool about Ted is as you see an
unfolding sequence of these people one
after the other the connections between
them start to become apparent it's
incredible just to spot themes parallel
themes and you can see like that matches
what I do or that matches what they do
maybe we should get together and just
even talking about things spreading
ideas you know ideas worth spreading is
not a bad slogan to have we've added a
new international Fellows program that
we call Ted fellows that brings together
extraordinary individuals from around
the world to participate in the Ted
community both by coming to conferences
and being part of an ongoing social
network throughout the year the Fellows
Program allows a kind of a seedling
process to go on and cultivate and
sustains the the kind of passion and
firing because there was something about
Ted it was getting to be a place where
already brilliant people met other
already brilliant people too yeah and
and if you're not already brilliant well
you know so there was no process whereby
you could be nurtured mentored and grow
along with the group the TED Fellows
program is focusing on attracting
candidates from five parts of the world
Asia Pacific Africa the Caribbean Latin
America and the Middle East all the
people from the rest
the world are welcome to apply we're
also searching for candidates who are 21
to 40 years old although once again
anyone 18 years and older is also
welcome to apply we're looking for
makers and doers not just talkers or not
just people that amazing potential we
want to see someone that's already done
something extraordinary and that we see
a trajectory for them to increase the
effectiveness of whatever endeavor they
are studying or pursuing at dead I
believe they're showing us the
opportunities and I could take that
learning back and show others what
opportunities do exist so that they can
move forward there's the incredible
community of people who genuinely want
to see these fellows thrive so whether
they're wealthy or incredibly
accomplished or whether they want a
mentor or coach this community is coming
together around the TED Fellows and
volunteering to help the Fellows program
was funded by people who didn't need to
care about us they just could have come
to Ted and enjoy Ted with all the
wonderful people they didn't need to
care they you know they just took their
attention they look at us they said
these people are worth something maybe
we should listen to them and they set up
this wonderful show this wonderful
program and we are here and they are
thanking us for being here one of the
most powerful ways in which we can help
the Ted fellows is offering them the
platform of Ted calm in addition to
putting up a directory of their profiles
and letting them blog in a continuous
narrative on the Ted fellows blog we
also offer them the opportunity to speak
at Ted record what they say and then put
it up on Ted comm where they will reach
an audience much larger than they've
ever reached before
I am in love with the pit talks and I
mean like I try to watch one a week and
I use them in my anthropology courses
all the time I've never seen something
that's so palpable the students make
them feel connected to the world beyond
the classroom so readily I really want
to be as present and engaged as possible
as I can as just a student of life here
I won't meet mentors and teachers like
this all at one fell swoop in a nutshell
Ted
is four days of intellectual stimulation
creativity conversations and some of the
best talks you've ever seen in your life
that literally leave your brain ready to
explode with all the new creative
connections that inspired you to go back
to your own work with great new ideas
great new creativity and a renewed sense
of optimism and hope about the world
it's like what Einstein said when you
think differently
you know different things but you need a
different way of thinking if you want
the world's change and it actually gives
us powerful and flat
you